Leveransproblem.
Och med det sagt kan man tycka varför bryr sig inte mer e-handlare om någonting mer än bara kostnaden.
För någonstans hänger ju en dålig leveransupplevelse och en lågkostnad ihop.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rendesbra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta men...
Alltså man tar det positivt.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Elin Morales här igen till podden och hon är vd på Airme och jag tror att alla som lyssnar på podden redan vet vilka Airme är eftersom man antagligen skickar ganska mycket paket och liknande.
Men om man nu inte vet det så är ju det någon sorts last mile aktör som gör det lite trevligare att skicka ut paketen till kunder.
Är det så man säger?
Hur beskriver du er grej till skillnad från andra fraktiga er?
Ja men det stämmer, vi är en hemleveransstjänst som möjliggör snabba och precisa leveranser till tror jag att det är 10 miljoner, 11 miljoner hushåll i Sverige och Danmark, sju dagar i veckan på kvällstid.
Så är jag med, jag är en partner till de största e-handlarna i Sverige och vårt fokus är att se till att den sista delen av leveransupplevelsen blir så bra som möjligt för konsumenten.
Och det vi har lärt oss genom åren är att vara fokuserad på att bra för konsumenten betyder ofta snabbt och den dagen man har sagt att man ska komma på.
Så det är det fokuset som vi har i våran tjänst.
Jag tänker att vi hoppar lite el in först och så bara nördar jag lite in i själva fraktdelen här så kan vi säga hej och sånt sen.
Är ni bara den sista delen eller är ni också lite upphämtning?
Hanterar ni logistiken i mitten eller partner ni upp med andra fraktbolag där?
Vi är, både egentligen som ett breddedel av konceptet, så är vi ju den helen operativa leveranstjänsten och den börjar som du säger hos e-handlarnas lager och upphämtningen där och sen går ju den hela vägen ut till slutkonsumentens hem eller skåp.
Vi har ju även skåpleveranser och hela den här kedjan möjliggörs genom vår egen tekniska plattform.
Så vi har totalt täckt egentligen de tekniska bitarna som krävs.
Alltifrån API för att vi ska visas i kassan till apparna som förena använder på sista milen för att man ska kunna skapa en leveransupplevelse där konsumenten från sin app eller spårningssida ska kunna följa sin leverans från det att den hämtas upp och se handlarnas i dess att den levereras.
Men har ni egna stora logistikcentra eller är ni en plattform som ligger på andra fraktbolag?
Vi är en kombination.
Vi har hela terminalverksamheten.
Vi har fyllt terminaler i Sverige.
Sen har vi hubbar runt om på mindre orter.
Sen samarbetar vi med underleveratörer i form av åkerier som sköter själva frakterna.
Vi har inga anställda förare eller egna bilar.
Det är väl den delen där vi skiljer oss från mer traditionella aktörer som Postnord och DHL och så vidare.
UPS har också den här modellen som vi har så det är väl egentligen inget konstigt att jobba med ett underleverantörsnätverk.
Det har ju gjort att vi kan fokusera väldigt mycket på att bygga den tekniska plattformen som ska möjliggöra hela tjänsten.
Men det är ju såklart en styrka att både sitta på tekniken och sedan leveranserna som går genom tekniken för att hela tiden optimera och förbättra våra flöden.
Och det är inte så att de är större, vi säger som D&L-skänker och postnord typ, eller DSV kanske också, där de köpte väl upp skänker.
Men de vill inte bara jacka in i er plattform och bli en del.
Det är inte dit världen rör sig eller?
Någonstans var det nog det i början och kanske inte så är det i början det, att allting handlade om att man skulle bygga en teckningsplattform så att kunna optimera varenda typ av leverans istäder.
Det var grundidén till Ermi, just för att kunna optimera transporterna, istäder och minska antal bilar som behövs, minska utsläppen och så vidare.
Så från början var det tanken när det var så plattformen byggdes.
Samtidigt så kom ju covid och e-handelsleveranserna började bli så stora, så det var ganska snabbt att man började lägga fokus på att själv genomföra leveranserna, för att det var också ett sätt att kunna bygga plattformen så att den blev så bra som möjligt.
För har du ingen data så är det ganska svårt att göra en bra ruttningsalgoritm till exempel, eller bygga verktyg som krävs.
Och sen har ju den delen av Ermi växt, och idag så är ju vi en stor aktör på den svenska marknaden, jag tror vi har runt 4 procent marknadsandel.
Men vi samarbetar ju med vissa parter också inom de här biterna, så jag ska inte säga att det ena utersluter det andra, men någonsin så finns det ju en fördel att ha ett tekniska system som kan optimera, och jag tror att det finns många större parter som skulle må bra att ta lite mer mognad i den biten också.
Ja, kan vi inte snacka lite skit om konkurrenter?
Jag fattar att du inte får göra det, men jag kan ju göra det.
Och vi använder ju dessutom, vi använder ju skänker, men vi har givetvis använt DHL och Bring och alla de här.
Och vårt stora problem är ju att vi skickar väldigt stora sändningar, säga att de ligger på typ 250 kilo i våra snittårdar eller något sånt där.
Och nu, typ något år sedan eller så där, så började man liksom jobba med kontaktfria leveranser, eller att man fick någon sorts fönster på fyra timmar.
Alltså det är ju fortfarande extremt trögt.
Vi är ju verkligen i spektrumet av bedrövliga leveranser när det kommer till kontroll.
Visst kan man välja dag och man kan välja liksom ett visst fönster.
Men om vi jämför med, om en eran tjänst då för det är klart att vi klickar hem grejer ibland.
Det är ju en helt annan tracking-förmåga och det är en helt annan kolumn.
Alltså, ja du vet ju hur eran tjänster funkar och jag vill inte ställa in den.
Men liksom, vad är det som är så jävla svårt med att planera en rutt?
Varför får de inte, varför funkar det liksom inte?
Vad är det som är så fruktansvärt komplicerat?
De måste ju ha enorma mängder data som visar hur snabbt det går och liknande.
Ja, nu vet ju inte jag exakt hur deras tjänster fungerar men det är ju många av de stora som inte har sin egenbyggda ruttningsalgoritm utan man använder ett system.
Och det är klart att du kan anpassa det systemet efter din egen dator men det blir nog aldrig så bra som när du själv inhouse bygger och optimerar ut efter den tjänsten som du ska leverera.
Och kanske er fall som har stora, tyngre, ganska otympliga leveranser, det skiljer sig från att ha små paket.
Och vem vet att den största delen av leveranserna är ju små paket och det är ju rimligt att tro att tjänsterna också kanske är mer optimerade för mindre paket och det kan ju också påverka hur tjänsten blir för de större sändningarna.
Så det finns nog väldigt mycket att göra där och de större sändningar skiljer sig också, här behöver du ju någon som är hemma.
Och där kanske spårningen är ännu viktigare än det paketet som du ska lägga.
Exakt det, så jag tänker det hade ju varit ännu mer rimligt att man optimerade.
Ja, så att jag har ingen bra svar på den frågan, men det vi har lärt oss i alla åren är ju datan och det är inte bara att optimera rötterna, utan det är ju ta ut datan för att förstå vad gick fel igår.
Vilka kunders lufter missade vi på att leverera igår och vad kan vi göra idag för att det inte ska ske igen?
Jag tror att det agila arbetssättet kräver ett att du har bra data så att dagen därpå, vi satt precis i vårt morgonmöt och kunde se exakt hur många leveranser vi hade folerat på igår och sen gå ner och se vad var det som hände och vad ska vi göra idag för att göra det bättre.
Jag tror att för att kunna göra det bra så behöver du datan och för att få datan så behöver du dina system och folk som fattar vad man ska göra med datan.
Det tror jag bolag som är lite nya och lite snabbfotare är bättre på än de mer traditionella, att det är mycket längre cykler i form av datan händer och att du kan göra någonting åt det, då kanske den opportunityn att förbättra är borta.
Hur räknar man in?
Nu blir jag lite halvkrånglig med småfrågor men det är för att jag tycker att det är kul.
Du har dessutom även jobbat redan i bolaget.
Du kom in som CFO så du är inte bara trevlig mot personal, utan du fattar ju också.
Bara förutsätter jag.
Men när du säger att ni fallerar på en leverans, säg då till exempel att det är en port som är låst eller säg att det är en katt som springer över vägen och typ förar en väger eller något sånt där.
Udda grejer, hur räknar man in det systemet?
Det måste ju hända varje dag att någonting skiter sig som inte föraren kunde förutse.
Hur anpassar man för det?
För om det händer vid första porten så måste det krascha hela systemet eller?
Nej men jag tror att det är nog de delarna som man inte, eller som är den lilla bufferten som man har.
Så vi har ju ett leveransprecisionsmål på 98,5% i år.
Och det lämnar ju en en halv procent för just den här typen av...
Åh, en hel en och en halv procent.
Ja, nej men det är ju den, nej men när jag kom in och började var det så här varför ska vi inte sätta 100%?
Och sen har jag ju förstått att ja men det är faktiskt en orimlig idé, det är faktiskt orimligt, det går inte att sätta det till 100%.
Så den en en halv procenten är ju just de yttre omständigheterna som, om så görs man inte lyckas av, ja det kan också vara ett bud som blir inlåst i hissen.
Menar du då att det är en och en halv procent av leveranserna som inte levereras, eller att det är en och en halv procent extra tid som man har på varje leverans?
Nej utan det blir de som inte levereras på den dagen som vi har sagt att det ska levereras.
Men sen räknar vi om vi kommer till en kund och portkoder som kunderna angett inte funkar så anser vi att vi har gjort det man har kunnat.
Man måste ringa kunden två gånger, man måste vänta minst 30 sekunder för att kunden ska svara och så vidare.
Sen det finns ju många konstiga bud som låser in sig mellan innergårdar och blir fast.
Det finns så många konstiga delar men där får man planera med marginal att kunna ha en extra som kan sticka in.
Det finns många olika delar man kan göra men vårt jobb handlar mycket om att kontrollera det vi kan kontrollera så att det finns utrymme för yttreomständigheter att ske.
Det är nog vad vårt fokus ska ligga på för att annars i den här branschen kan du alltid skylla på någonting.
Det var den svel eller det var det eller det var katten eller det var...
Då kommer man inte framåt tillräckligt fort.
Hur gör man för att få...
Jag var tidningsbudd en gång för länge sen och då fanns det till exempel ett hus som jag åkte uppe i där den hissen, det är inte så trevligt men den luktade kiss.
Det var ingen trevlig hiss utan det var uppenbart någon som kissade i den hissen.
Jag kanske inte brydde mig as mycket om mitt jobb just då så jag kanske då och då bara sket i det huset att gå in där.
Hur säkerställer ni att inte bara buden snackar skit typ och säger att porten funkar inte?
Det blir ju datan också att kunna se mönster och att kunna se avvikelser som sticker ut.
Man kan se hur mycket missar vi snitt.
Är det någon som ligger utanför den hissen och sen kan man ju skära ner det på områden.
För datan kan ju också vara farlig att du bara drar allting på ett average och drar slutsatser på det.
Men våran erfarenhet att datan, om du skär den rätt och vet vad du ska leta efter, ska ge dig mycket insikter som du sen kan kontrollera om det stämmer i verkligheten.
Så det man kan se i vissa områden är ju, oj den här fararen sticker ut på misslyckade leveransförsök.
Då kan man ju börja gräva i, var det bara en dag?
Nej men det är varje dag, det är hela tiden.
Och då har man med den datan till fararens ansvar, kan man ta, hej, det ser ut som att vi har ett mönster här, vad kan vi göra åt det?
Och just datan blir ju ett sådant viktigt hjälpmedel i våran bransch, det mycket annars är, som ni säkert kommer ihåg från den tiden.
Alltså det går ju att förklara bort nästan allt, men någonstans i flera datapunkter under längre tid, det ljuger ofta inte.
Så med det som bas, då kan man börja ta action.
Men vi har nästan helt ut i slutet att ta action som inte är på data, för det är lätt också för motparten.
Att skilja bort så blir det helt icke konstruktiv dialog på den biten.
Men när jag skulle säga att man följer mönster och man tar action på mönster, så klart målet är att säkerställa att alla som jobbar känner att de inte vill ta shortcuts.
Men det är ett annat långsiktigt sätt som man alltid jobbar på, men det är väl den balansen man vill hitta.
Alla vill göra det rätt, och när de gör fel så kanske det är något annat som är bakgrund till det.
Ni har ju några konkurrenter som gör liknande tjänster.
Finns det något som är sant, unikt med just AirMe, eller är det mer att du då givetvis anser att ni försöker lite hårdare eller är lite trevligare såhär, eller finns det någonting i tjänsten som är liksom sant, unikt?
Jag skulle nog säga att det är vårt fokus på snabbheten i leveransen.
Vi har ju sedan, AirMe grundades haft fokuset på att samma dag leveranser, expressleveranser, två timmars leveranser, nu vårt grundarbrudden, vi har en samma dagtjänst som betyder att tar vi ingotset innan klockan 14 eller stopptider i lite olika städer så levererar vi det samma kväll för övriga sju dagar i veckan.
För övriga som kanske inte har möjligheter att producera en samma dag så hämtar vi ofta sen kväll och levererar vi dagarna på så det blir next day inom 24 timmar.
Att kunna göra det och kombinera det och ett och samma ruttningssystem på ett sätt som skalar sju dagar i veckan i alla städer i Sverige på ett kostnads-effektivt sätt.
Det är det som gör att vi kan ha och kan växa våra marknadsandel väldigt mycket nu.
Jag ska inte säga att någon annan inte kan göra det, men det är dyrt och svårt att göra det i skala om man inte hela tiden har jobbat på optimerade.
Så jag skulle säga att vi har ett försprång i den delen och i det fokuset på just snabbheten att kunna göra det i skala och kunna göra det på ett sätt som inte kostar dubbelt så mycket som en vanlig leverans.
Det var faktiskt min nästa fråga.
Hur mycket dyrare, sen kan vi prata kunnigt där på det givetvis, men i och med att systemet blir såpass snabbt då och att leveransen blir lite mer personlig, vad är liksom den extra kostnaden egentligen?
Hur mycket dyrare blir det att göra en sak samma dag jämfört med att ha någon sorts traditionellt en till tre dagars fönster typ?
I vår värld är faktiskt samma dagstjänsten billigare att producera en nästa dag.
Tack vare det arbetet som EANN har på sin sida också.
De försorterar ofta så att vi kan hämta.
Vi har EANN i norr om Stockholm till exempel, som antingen själva lämnar in till våra norra Stockholms terminaler att vi hämtar och då är det försorterat.
Så vi behöver egentligen bara toucha paketet en gång.
Det går rakt in i vår samma dagssortering, utbud och sen vidare ut på rutten.
Så hanteringskostnaden är inte nödvändigtvis större.
Sen är det ju klart svårare att planera, alltså optimera rutten för vi har ju ungefär 60 procent av vårt gods finns i vår system på morgonen så vi kan lägga en grund rutplanering så att alla terminaler kan börja sortera.
Sedan har vi estimerat hur mycket samma dag volym kommer in och ska ju fylla på samma rutter då och kunna maximera fyllnadsgraden och det är inte helt lätt att göra men det har vi gjort eftersom jag jobbar med det här så många år så har det blivit väldigt, väldigt bra så att där finns det ju en viss, det kanske är en två kronor att hämta in om man bara skulle ha nästa dag volymer men det är inte så mycket mer än så och det är egentligen en två kronor som du sparar på att det inte touchar paketer två gånger för det är e-handlaren och många e-handlare har ju sorteringsattamation nu så att det inte kostar så mycket mer för dem att försortera.
Så från det perspektivet så är det inte så mycket dyrare än en vanlig leverans men du behöver ju bra systemstöd för att kunna möjliggöra det och ändå kunna hålla en bra finlandsgrad i bilen.
Min känsla är att ni gör ganska mycket kvällsleveranser eller att det liksom är en...
Bara kvällsleveranser, ja.
Ja okej, det är en stor fördel för mig som kund men det måste vara rätt krångligt.
Är det inte krångligt att anställa folk på den premissen att man jobbar det tidsfönstret?
Stor del.
Den största delen av vårat arbete på terminalerna där jag har egen anställda men ändå kombinerat med med bemannning så sker jobbet på en vanlig arbetsdag så att säga.
Utan det är vi av våra underleverantörers förare.
Ja just det, ni har ju underleverantörer ja, just det.
Men de har ju, det är många studenter, det är många som har det här som ett extra jobb.
För det här är ju inte ett heltidsjobb.
Timmarna är ju inte åtta timmar så det är många som kompletterar sina studer eller annat med den här typen av jobb.
Sen jobbar vi såklart för att kunna hitta vägar att göra det till en mer anställning, men det är inte så det funkar idag.
Så många har det som ett extra jobb helt enkelt.
Det finns ju, det är inte så att, det finns väldigt många som ser det här som en bra möjlighet till sitt första jobb, till ett extra jobb, och många delar ett instängsjobb.
Det kanske är första jobbet och det enda man kan få till att börja med och sen växa vidare på.
Nu kan vi, nu kan vi, nu kan vi, det känns som att jag har kört en jättestor jävla utfrågning i tillfället.
Det är kul, det är bara att fortsätta.
Ja, jag älskar sånt där så att, men om vi tar lite kort om dig idag, efter sådär 20 minuter, eller du har ju gjort, du kom in i företaget som CFO, om jag förstår det rätt.
Ja, det stämmer.
Och sen, och sen fick du ta över personalansvar och nu är du vd, har jag fattat det rätt då?
Ja, på pappret så har du fattat det rätt då.
Kan du inte ge mig hela resan när du kom in, varför din resa gick åt det hållet, och bara ge mig liksom the timeline.
Ja, men jag kan backa bandet lite, men innan jag kom till Ermin, jag har ju bara jobbat under entreprenörer.
Hela min professionella, sen gick jag ut handelsen 15 år sedan, så jag har jobbat i entreprenörsdrivna bolag.
Och innan jag kom i kontakt med Ermin, så hade jag två resor bakom mig i bolag, med väldigt starka gründare, väldigt starka visioner och stora höga mål.
När du säger väldigt starka grunda, var de skitjobbiga, är det det det betyder?
Nej men gründare är skitjobbiga, men jag gillar det.
Du får filtrera det och så får du se fördelarna med att man får så sjukt mycket frihet om man filtrerar bort.
Jag har blivit väldigt skolad i att jobba nära gründare och för mig har det alltid varit väldigt mycket mer fördelar och nackdjare om man säger så.
Men det är också ganska krävande såklart att jobba i den här typen av bolag.
Det är högtempo, det är snabbpressas vidare.
Så när jag kommer i kontakt med Ermi så var jag ganska försiktig med ska jag hoppa på en till entreprenörsresa nu som entreprenör.
När jag vet hur mycket jag själv liksom går in helhjärtat i den här typen av uppdrag.
Så jag utvärderade Ermi mycket som om man var en investerare, finns marknaden, är den tillräckligt stor för att Ermi ska kunna bli någonting och den boxar var ganska lätt att checka.
Givet e-handelsmarknaden, Ermi leverans, Logisil optimerar det.
Sen nummer två så kände jag också väldigt starkt, jag ville ha ett starkt mission, någonting mer än att bara jobba för ett bolag.
Och Ermi problemet är, som Julian och Idrian som grundade bolag satte ut för att lösa, handlade ju om att hur kan vi möjliggöra världens bästa konsumentupplevelse i leveransen, det vill säga snabbhet, bekvämlighet, flexibilitet, utan att det är dåligt för miljön eller städerna som vi bor i.
Hur löser vi den ekvationen?
För att vi trodde inte då, och liksom gründare trodde inte det, att konsumenterna kommer inte vilja ha, ge mig fem dagars leverans, utan då kommer det bara gå snabbare och snabbare och snabbare.
Så det är branschen som måste komma på ett sätt att göra det mer hållbart än traditionella betoder.
Den utmaningen lockades jag av att med hjälp av teknik och innovation, förändra och förbättra sättet.
Sen var det tredje delen att återigen jobba under en grundare, det var ganska såklart, du försökte vettas så mycket som möjligt, Julian som grundade Ermi och sedan Idrian som är den tekniska grundaren, men kände också ganska starkt att de här personerna har, jag trodde i alla fall, vad som krävs för att verkligen kunna få det här att hända.
Så det var anledningen till att jag hoppade på Ermi.
Då var ju på papperet CFO, men vi var fyra personer, så jag spenderade mer tid att få siffrorna att hända än att sitta och räkna på dem.
Så jag jobbade ju super mycket med sälj under de första åren och alltid jobbade väldigt nära våra operationella metrics, egentligen byggt upp alla metrics som vi nu i dag följer.
Och jag tror hela min regressa på Army.
Jag hade kvar Cifo Staff-rollen i över ett år sedan, jag var som vd för jag har aldrig fokuserat så mycket på rollen, utan för mig är det bara handlat om hur ska vi få vår revolution att hända snabbast möjliga sätt och hur kan jag bäst hjälpa till med det.
Jag köper det.
Så det är egentligen bara något som har, det blev liksom bara en följsam resa för dig, det var inte såhär steg...
Nej men det var, jag kom in som Cifo och sen tog jag föräldraledighet 2021 och då var det ganska naturligt att man började, då hade ju Ermi vuxit, vi omsatte strax under 200 miljoner då tror jag.
Så det var ganska naturligt att börja bygga upp finansteamet för framtiden.
Det var jag Cifo och sen hade jag en redovisningskonsult som inte var helt i sin ställ, utan var någon som jobbade med en gång i månaden och klarat månadsbokslutet.
Så det var ganska naturligt givet den size som vi var, att börja bygga ett finansteam.
Så det passade rätt bra när jag skulle på föräldraledighet rekrytera in en Cifo och börja bygga mer ekonomiteamet.
Och sen naturligt för mig att komma tillbaka och fokusera mer på Cifo-staff på Ermi handlar mer vd-högre hand snarare än HR-chef.
Så ja, jag hade viss HR-ansvar men samma sak där, mitt jobb var att få saker att hända enligt de planer som jag hade satt på bästa möjliga sätt.
Jag tänker att du inte saknar Cifo-staff-jobb för det personal är väl alltid skitjobbigt.
Men om du är en sån här siffermänniska kan du sakna den delen av jobbet som är mycket mer konkret typ.
Ja men jag har fortfarande ingen Cifo och jag är ju Cifo-anlänges så jag har ju i siffrorna fortfarande ansvar för det och för mig är det att jag skulle inte vilja att någon annan satt på det yttersta.
Det är det som möjliggör att man kan driva eller få koll på hur verksamheten går varje dag och kunna veta vart jag sen ska lägga energin på.
Så siffrorna skulle jag nog aldrig vilja släppa helt men det är skönt att få dem mer presenterade för sig än att behöva göra jobbet själv.
Ja, jag tänker nu har vi varit i en sådan här period som har varit, nu känns det som det börjar luckras upp lite igen men nu känns det som vi har varit i en period när om man inte går plus så ska man typ skjutas.
Och ni är ju ett företag som ändå har gått med underskott även om det liksom taktar på bättre och bättre eller med mindre och mindre underskott och ni fortsätter att växa och växa och växa.
Så har det ändå gått med underskott.
Hur har det varit att driva under de åren?
Jag tror det man måste förstå i den bransch som vi är i, vi är i en bransch, vad ska man säga på svenska, vi måste förlora mycket pengar innan vi kan tjäna pengar för det är en hel 100 procent low margin high volume business.
Och det har ju varit tydligt från dag ett.
Sen har man ju alltid önskat att volymen ska komma snabbare än vad man har tänkt.
Men det har varit tydligt för oss i bolag, tydligt för de investerare som har gått in i vad det är för typ av affärsmodell man investerar i.
Du behöver en viss skala för att kunna tjäna pengar i den här branschen.
Och där har ju den viktiga delen varit att hela tiden visa att det håller i verkligheten för man kan ju tänka sig att bara vira sig på med mer volym i systemet så blir allting bra.
Men du måste exekvera på den volymen och se till att du hela tiden får mer i skalfördelarna av den volymen och det är inte helt enkelt men det är det vi har lyckats göra så bra.
Vi har ju från 2022 skulle jag säga när de flesta började skruva om och gå mot lönsamhet så fortsatte vi egentligen på det arbetet som vi hela tiden har jobbat med att optimera.
Gm1, gm2, gm3 som hela tiden rör sig mot svarta siffror och det vi lyckades göra var att fortsätta växa samtidigt.
Och nu i år så växer vi med, senaste två kvartalen har vi växt med över 65% year over year.
Vi kliver faktiskt över nu i oktober på positiv ebit och vi ser att det kommer att fortsätta.
Så nu har vi verkligen bevisat den delen också på hela, även om vår hemleverans i Sverige har varit lönsam men under längre tid så är det ändå fler delar som ska stämma och nu är vi verkligen på andra sidan och det är ganska få last mile-bolag som har lyckats styra om till lönsamhet samtidigt som man har bibehållet tillväxten.
Så väldigt metodiskt arbete mot de svarta siffrorna och hela tiden se till att man konverterar den ökade volymen till bättre marginaler på ett eller annat sätt.
Kan vi inte nörda där lite grann ut, du behöver inte säga alla är hemligheter, sådär.
Men ni, om man säger det här i 2022 då, så kanske ni, ja men då gick ni typ 100 miljoner back och så omsatte ni typ 300 miljoner ungefär.
Och nu förra året så gick ni typ 30 miljoner back och omsatte 370 miljoner och säger att ni växer 65 procent.
Då är ni uppe på nästan, säger att ni är uppe på typ någon halv miljard och så går ni några enstaka miljoner back.
Ni har ju en konkurrent till exempel som är, då om ni växer med 65 procent är de inte så där galet mycket större längre.
Men de är ju fortfarande större men de gör ju ett betydligt mycket större minusresultat.
Vad är det liksom konkret som ni gör som gör att ni ändå lyckas bibehålla en så pass liten förlustaffär om vi ska kalla det då under tillväxten?
För det är ju inte så att ni har haft en, även när ni gick mycket minus så hade ni ingen galen minussiffra om man tittar på jämförbara företag.
Även om jag som privat e-handlare kan tycka att helvete det är mer än vad jag omsätter på ett år.
Så är det liksom, det är fortfarande inte som du säger, ni måste gå minus under en viss fas.
Men vad är det ni gör bättre tror du?
Ni får skryta lite grann, skit i de här andra människorna nu.
Vad är det liksom bolaget faktiskt lyckas med?
Men jag tror att man ska komma ihåg att när Ermi grundades, vi pratade om dem då som är mer likvärde på hemleveranser.
De hade tagit in 350 miljoner.
Så någonstans var det så här, Ermi borde inte ens ha funnits, givet den avståndet som fanns mellan de två bolagen.
Jag tror att det gjorde att mindsetet på Ermi från början var att vi var tvungna att tänka annorlunda, vi var tvungna att vara mer kreativa i allt vi gjorde.
Vi hade inte samma kassa bakom oss i form av Kinnevik, till exempel där och Instabox hade också väldigt stark ägare.
Vi hade också stark ägare men kanske inte med samma muskler.
Så från dag 1 fick vi prata om marginaler.
Mitt första uppdrag var att räkna ut bröttermarginal 1.
Det var minus 110 procent.
Så det var första...
Ja, det var första.
Ja, vi har fått fram en modell nu så att vi kan följa bröttermarginal 1 varje dag.
Vad är den på då?
Minus 110 procent.
Oj, men då blev det målt.
Okej, vilken produktivitet per timme behöver vi få för att halvera den?
För att sen gå till nollan.
Sedan så byggde vi hela vår operationella modell och alla som jobbade i bolaget då.
För det var ju väldigt mycket fokus på sista milen, hur optimerar vi ruttena, hur jobbar vi med trafikledning, med support intervuden.
Hela den modellen sattes under de första åren.
Det vi gjorde var att vi satte datapunkter i händerna på de som faktiskt är närmast problemen, de som sitter med dem i delarna varje dag och byggde metrics.
Och att även om du är ny, eller nyexad, det är inte ens det, du kommer direkt från gymnasiet och börjar jobba extra som trafikledare, så har du ett ansvar varje dag.
Och du har möjligheten att påverka de siffrorna från gårdagen och sätta mycket ansvar på de som faktiskt kan påverka och gör det tydligt för dem hur de kan vara med och bidra till helheten.
Jag tror att den sifferuppföljningen i kombination med att ge ansvar till de som faktiskt kan påverka varje dag och få deras engagemang i att vilja påverka, vilja vara kreativ och vilja hela tiden komma med nya lösningar, det har varit en framgångsfaktor som egentligen har skalat i varenda del av våran operativa verksamhet.
Vi har en väldigt platt organisation, vi är väldigt få i jämförelse som inte jobbar operationellt och att hela vårt non-operationella team, vi jobbar för att göra det operationella teamets arbete så mycket bättre och sen har vi också kombinationen av att vi har den tekniska plattformen som sparar mycket timmar åt oss och i logistiken och operationella så är det någon sådär timmar som gör att det kostar pengar.
Jag tror att vi, tack vare tekniken, tack vare vårt arbetssätt och tack vare att vi jobbar så datadrivet gör att vi använder mindre timmar egentligen för allt och det visar sig ju i siffrorna.
Du sa att de får ta egna, alltså man får liksom förbättra siffrorna eller vad man ska säga.
Hur tar det sig ut, kan du ge något exempel på det?
Jag har ett ganska bra exempel faktiskt på senare år.
För ett och ett halvt år sen så slog vi ihop vår supportorganisation.
Förut hade vi kundtjänst och sen så hade vi de som var support till förena.
Vi slog ihop det i en organisation och sen så kollade vi på vad att kosta supporten per leverans.
Support kostar per leverans för en stor del är klart att du har en manager, du har en team lead men annars är det ganska rörlig kostnad som går mot stor volym, mer supporttickets och så vidare.
Men det vi gjorde var att till supportmanagern så satte vi målet att minska supporttickets för varje leverans.
Total leverans volym.
Och ta det till teamet.
Vi vet inte var det som driver de här olika typen av supporttickets, men kom fram till det och började jobba för att reducera dem.
Och det är typiskt så här top down.
Ja, de har ett kostnadsmål.
Ja, de har en metric men de får friheten att komma på vad de ska göra för att driva neråt.
Och på det här ett och ett halvt året så har vi halverat supportkostnader per enhet och det är ju av en halv miljon i besparing på dagens volym och det är enbart drivit över den agila sättet som de jobbar inom sitt team.
Och mycket går ju ifrån att förstå.
Föraren följde inte instruktionerna i appen, kunden skrev in och var sur.
Okej, vad kan vi uppdatera för instruktioner till föraren så att de inte gör det här problemet?
Varför skrev kunden in?
Hade vi kunnat mötta det på ett annat sätt tidigare?
Kan vi uppdatera flödet innan du kommer i kontakt med kundtjänst så att de får svaren lättare?
Kan vi göra uppdateringar i appen?
Kan vi, alltså hela den delen som är vår support managers roll handlar mycket om att optimera de här grejerna.
Snarare kanske än att coacha och utbilda personalen.
Det finns en team lead som ansvarar för det.
Men den här typen av uppsättning så funkar alla våra operationella managers.
De har metrics att jobba på och sen har de friheten tillsammans med sitt team optimera dem, helt enkelt.
Hur gör man för att få det att inte bli att folk väljer att ta, vad ska vi kalla det då, genvägar, men säga att du ska optimera antalet support ärenden typ.
Det allra eller enklaste är att inte svara.
Jag säger inte att det är det folk gör, jag bara menar att om du har till exempel en team leader som vill komma lite framåt så kan ju de fejka siffror i tre månader innan det syns att de har bara skitit i vissa ärenden, typ för det är de krångliga ärendena som kostar pengar.
Hur gör man, ska du säga, data igen nu då?
Nej men vi har faktiskt alltid två olika typer av metrics, en är kostnad och en är kvalitet.
Så de sitter alltid ihop, sen kan vi välja, nu vill vi optimera mer här men du har alltid den andra siffran som sitter, sen kan man välja hur ska man navigera då men då måste det alltid rapporteras i någon slags kombination och sen just i det fallet hade man fortfarande sett det för det hade fortfarande varit ärende in.
Så den hade inte minskat men det är nog samma sak där att känna att de personerna som jobbar med det har ägandeskap.
Jag tror att det är ganska lätt att se igenom om någon sitter och presenterar siffror som de själv inte på ett engagerande sätt kan backa upp då och man hör massor av killgissningar som jag kallar det för.
Det är ganska lätt att slå hål på tidigt.
Ja, jag förstår.
Från e-handelssidan så är ju fraktleverantören är ju vår mest hatade kostnad och antagligen vår mest hatade samarbetspartner i många fall.
Det är ju ofta där man lägger mycket pengar och om man kollar på Trustpilot och liknande så är det ju väldigt ofta liksom att det var dålig leverans.
Det är ju det vi e-handlare hatar för att det var inte vårt fel, du vet.
Så hur gör man hela den dialogen med en fraktleverantör för att det ska bli bra?
Och vad kan vi göra tänkte jag också säga.
Hur påverkar det det?
Det är nog ett att se det mer som ett parterskap och att man förstår båda sidorna.
Vi som leverantör behöver förstå fokuset som e-handlaren har.
Är det här ett bolag som fokuserar enormt mycket på lönsamhet?
Då förstår vi att leveransen kommer att vara kostnad och den kommer att vara stor.
Då kanske inte vi går in och säljer in den mest optimala kvällsleveransen.
För vi vet att de kommer inte att ha öppet på kvällen för de kommer inte vilja sätta OB-timmar på kvällen.
Men hur kan vi göra utifrån de förutsättningarna som den här elen har på lagret då?
Hur kan vi göra en så bra leverans som möjligt ut efter deras befintliga flöden?
Hur kan vi ge er ett erbjudande som inte innebär att någon måste stanna en timme till?
Ja, men små saker att man förstår den andrasidas ett mål, två utmaningar så att vi kan anpassa vår lösning så att den passar bra in i deras flöde.
Det är den ena typen av case och sen att vi hela tiden ser till att följa upp.
Vi skickar kvalitetsrapporter, vi skickar månadsuppföljning.
E-handlarna har inte alltid tid att gå igenom det, men för oss är det ett sätt att visa att vi håller koll på de här grejerna och vi eskalerar internt om kvaliteten går under på den här, under en viss nivå.
För vi vet ju också att man vill undvika att det går till kundtjänst.
Kundtjänst är ju vår man vill ha det som bästa kompis med, för att det är där de får problemet när vi gör bort oss.
Där försöker vi i alla fall jobba att vi ser problemen innan de är att slå på kundtjänst att vara proaktiva där.
Sen finns det andra e-handlare som mer är i tillväxtcase.
Där jobbar vi mycket med dem.
Hur kan vi göra leveransen till en ökad konvertering för er?
Hur kan vi se till att de inte lämnar kassan för att de inte hade, leveranstiden var inte tillräckligt bra eller att ni inte hade leveransalternativer som vi ville ha.
Hur kan vi prissätta hemleveransen på ett sådant sätt att kostnaden är högre än en ombud, det är högre ett skåp.
Hur kan vi kanske prissätta den högre?
Kanske tjäna två kronor på hemleverans just för att den är en leverans som erbjuds ikväll.
Det behöver inte hela tiden vara en kostnad utan man kan även kolla på hela fraktnett och se prova att sätta 69 kronor.
Se till att det syns att det är ikväll.
Se till att ta bort arbetsdagar, lägg dagar, vi levererar på helger.
Vi är den enda som gör det.
Att man jobbar med e-handlare för att kunna presentera även värdet av leveransen hela vägen.
Och samma sak där, att sedan leverera på erbjudandet.
För oss handlar det mycket om att sätta de här bitarna, förstå kunden, förstå vad de jobbar på och jobba tillsammans med dem för att få en så bra leveransupplevelse som möjligt.
För som du säger, det är minst, tror att vi scrapeade hela Trustpilot förra året.
Alla reviews inom, jag vet inte hur många e-handlare, och så segmenterar vi det och då, ja, 40-60% är ju leveransproblem.
Så, och med det sagt så kan man tycka varför bryr sig inte mer e-handlare om någonting mer än bara kostnaden.
För någonstans så hänger ju en dålig leveransupplevelse och en lågkostnad ihop.
Ja, jag skulle säga att nästan, vi har ju ganska bra framtid, vi ligger på 4,8, så det är liksom, det är svårt att komma högre om man typ inte betalar folk eller vad man ska säga.
Men alla våra ettor är ju frakt.
Alltså det är ju så det är liksom.
Det kommer någon då och då, någon såhär var 50-ående, och det är liksom, jag fick inte min leverans, va fan ska vi göra åt det liksom.
Det var det.
Nej men, och det man vill göra är ju, vi har inte byggt det här men släpper väl det.
Men det jag skulle vilja, allting handlar om att vara proaktiv.
Tänk om du kunde få, din kundtjänst kunde få på morgonen, Ermi misslyckades med den där leveransen igår, den här kunden har skrivit in till oss de här grejerna, alltså att era kundtjänst på morgonen kunde, hej Joel, vi vet att det inte blev bra igår, vi har sett konversationen, det här är inte någonting leverantörerna är stolta på, det här är inte någonting vi är stolta på, vad kan vi göra?
Att kunna vara den som kan följa upp det innan kunden skriver den sura medelna på Trustpilot.
För någonstans är det så att saker och ting skiter sig i vår bransch, men ju snabbare och mer proaktivt man kan följa upp det, det är där hela vändningen av den här negativ revygen kan ske.
Har ni gjort några undersökningar på konvertering om man använder?
För nu låter det som att jag ska höja upp här.
Jag brukar försöka undvika att vara för snäll typ, men om jag läser era Trustpilot omdömen, så har ni 110 000 och ni ligger på ett snitt på 4,6.
Det är ju ganska hyggligt för att ha en fraktleverantör.
Och jag tänker att jag hänger ut på Snod för att det är lugnt.
De kan ta det.
De ligger på 2,6 i snitt på sina 70 000.
Och nu är det inte exakt samma grej, men vi har ju flera kunder som har frågat oss typ, kan ni ha er med?
Nej, vi skickar ju väldigt stora leveranser, det passar liksom inte riktigt med den och vi ligger i en avkrok med våra lager, så det passar inte heller i upphämtning och liknande.
Men har ni kollat konverteringsgrejen om era tjänster gör att ni får bättre?
Så som Klarna gjorde mycket när det var så här att våran checkout konverterar så här mycket bättre.
Är det något ni säljer in?
Jag önskar att jag hade siffrorna på det och jag...
Har ni inte det?
Jag försökte lobba upp en enkel smash här.
Men jag vet, men nu tror jag både Ingrid och Dema och de börjar få mer och mer data, men det är ganska krav.
Alltså, hur vet man exakt att det var just leveransdelen?
Hur vet man exakt att det krävs jobbet tester?
Men det vi kan se är...
Vi kan se konvertering till oss så klart.
Så vi kan ju se om vi positionerar oss på viss sätt i kassan.
Så ökar det konverteringen, sen kan vi se att 50 procent av det stannar kvar när vi går ner i kassan.
Så det finns ju någonting med att testa er med första gången.
Vi måste leverera på det luften så kommer någonting tillbaka.
Men jag är väldigt intresserad av att fortsätta få fram, och det jobbar vi på på olika sätt, att kunna se de här konverteringsdelarna.
Men i brist på den datan så har ju vårt fokus varit på leveransbelevelsen.
Vi ska sätta, när vi har valt då så ska vi sätta det.
Och det har vi gjort, vi har ju ingen marknadsföringsavdelning, vi gör ingen marknadsföring för leveransen är den bästa marknadsföringen som vi kan göra och jag tror att det indirekt har lett till vad vi tror är en ökad konvertering, men som sagt jag har inte data på det.
Det vi däremot har data på är hur man ökar konverteringen genom att kunna visa dator med kassan.
Att det står ett datum i kassan istället för en till tre dagar, det i sig ger en ökad konvertering.
Det är sådana data som till exempel Ingrid och kanske även Enshift sitter på.
Men den man skulle vilja ha är den här riktiga, aha du är med i kassan så ökar du konverteringen med x.
Men tyvärr inte.
Vad är det som är så knepigt med att lösa stora leveranser?
Varför jobbar man inte mot skriva?
För jag fattar att den stora majoriteten av frakter är en t-shirt eller en parfym eller en penna eller vad som helst.
Men om man kollar på hur mycket vi som leverantörer som skickar, vi skickar ju gymutrustning men det finns ju folk som skickar betong eller som skickar vitvaror eller som skickar möbler.
Alltså det är en ganska stor del av e-handeln som skickar sjukt tråkiga varor som tar väldigt mycket plats och där det verkligen är viktigt att kunden skulle vara hemma och ta emot.
För det är liksom den stora problematiken.
Man vill se det i realtid för man behöver åka hem från jobbet och vara där.
Och man kanske till och med behöver ta in en granne för man ska lyfta in 800 kilo ved.
Det finns en så stor, jag bara förstår inte varför så många verkar skita i den delen.
Men jag tror att det är svårt och vi gjorde ju balkiföret.
Vi gjorde nog inte i alla typer av produkter men vi gjorde ju, ja, vi hade ett helt balkiflöde.
Men det som var svårt är att göra det i kombination med småpaketsflödet.
Alltså, det är två helt olika affärsmedel.
Jag tror att det är det som är grejen att man vill fokusera, att man vill ha det agila så jag ska ju däremot säga att det finns någon möjlighet för någon att göra balki riktigt, riktigt bra.
Men då ska man nog göra det till helhetstjänsten och optimera och planera med det som bas och sen kanske slänga in en småpaket som får åka med lite billigare för att öka fyllnadsgraden men jag tror att det är det som är grejen att vara en tjänst och det är detsamma med badby också.
Den är optimerad för småpaket.
Det är hög prodiskrivitet, snabbaflöden och du kan liksom inte slänga in någonting större där.
Det rycker processer och det blir dykt men att däremot ha ett flöde som är dedikerat till att hantera balki och verkligen gör det riktigt bra.
Där tror jag finns en möjlighet men det är ganska svårt att göra dem i ett och samma ekosystem.
Är det att man måste få så stor volym i antal stora sändningar för att det ska funka?
Är det det man...
Det är också, men sen på Last Mile ska man också ha med sig att det är inte, man kanske tänker på Airmeans terminal till exempel, vi är två stycken, eller fem stycken i hela Sverige men två i Stockholm.
Det är ju inte som ett lager.
Det är inte i en stor lokal som har hyllor över hela och paket som står och lagras, utan det är ju kanske fyra timmar på dagen sådana riktigt mycket paket och sedan är det tomt.
När vi hade balk i fyra timmar per dag du också har riktigt stora grejer som tar väldigt stor plats och då behöver du mycket större grundytor.
Det är rätt svårt att kompensera för de övriga 20 timmarna på dygnet där den här avvaroarna inte står där.
Så det gör ju att hela infrastrukturen för att hantera balk i behöver vara större.
Det blir svårt att motivera när man dessutom ska optimera för små paketar är det ändå billigare och det är svårt att få ihop dem här i två flöden.
Så jag tror att det var efter peak 2022 nog som vi bara sa att nu lägger vi ner, att kombinera för nu, då var det också fysiskt platt så då blev det ganska jobbigt att ta sofforna och liksom, jag tror till och med julkranar på er sida och sen var det helt fullt.
Så jag tror att det är storleken men att det finns absolut möjlighet att göra någonting riktigt bra av det fladet.
Kan du säga vad är liksom den bästa produkten att skicka?
Om krångliga produkter som är tre meter långa är svinjobbiga att hantera, vad är liksom det smidigaste fraktflödet?
Är det paket på två kilo som går ner i brevlådor?
Nja, paket generellt.
Man ska faktiskt inte underskatta, jag skulle säga paket på ett och ett halvt kilo.
Ett enkelt liksom, tjugo gånger, fortio, vad var de med?
För är de för små, finns det också risk att de försvinner i bilen, de här riktigt små bre försändelserna.
Så det är en combo, men sen finns det en vits i att ha en liten del, lite större.
För det finns en stor del av rutten som ändå ska köras ut på sista milen som är körsträckor.
Du måste köra till första stoppet, du måste köra tillbaka till terminalen och har en kombination av lite mer god som har lite högre leveransvärde så får du en bättre unit economics på de fasta körtiderna.
Sedan ska nog inte den större volymgodset som en låda vin till exempel vara 50 procent av bilen, men det finns nog en grön på runt 10-15 procent lite tyngre och sedan har du små paket och sedan har du några riktigt små brevförkändelser i det också.
Så att du får ändra in rätt mycket i bilen.
Som slutpunkt här någonstans, vad kommer hända framöver?
Jag tycker att de flesta kunder börjar bli rätt tydligt styrda av frakt.
Man vill ha det på ett visst sätt, man handlar på ett annat sätt nu än vad man gjorde förr.
Och branschen har gått igenom ganska mycket utveckling bara på några år.
Folk tycker säkert att det går långsamt, men det har hänt ganska mycket från att du fick liksom, att den här dagen kanske vi kommer till att nu kan du på riktigt tracka ganska mycket.
Vad är nästa steg?
För att på något sätt drivs det också av ett lönsamhetskrav, att det måste bli ekonomiskt hållbart att göra det riktigt stort.
Och sen kanske man får i storstäder att man inte får köra mellan vissa tider, man får inte vara på vissa gator, man får inte vara...
Vad tror du kommer...
Hur kommer det se ut om tio år liksom?
Jag tror från konsumentens sida så kommer det fortsätta att gå in på data igen, men jag tror att det är data som kommer göra valet.
Det är så här, ja du kanske sätter in dina inställningar här, men jag gillar hemleverans som första alternativ, men jag gillar det viktiga för mig att den är i tid.
Och då kanske din agent optimerar, ja men just den här e-handeln har de här leveransrebjudorna och 97,8% av gångerna så kommer den här leverantören i tid, men det här ombudet kommer 100% av gångerna, ja men då tar vi det den här gången.
Det sker liksom en bakgrund med att man har sina preferenser, men någonstans är det datapunkter, snarare än känslor som styr.
Och datapunkter kan ju också vara Joel Raita, där de här leveransalternativet är så att automatiken i valen, snarare än känslor styrda, har varit från konsumenten eller e-handlarens logistikavdelning som sitter och väljer vad som ska synas i kassan.
Så tror jag att konsumentupplevelsen kommer att bli mer automatiskt män på konsumentens villkor beroende på vilka preferenser man vill ha.
De kan ju ändras.
Jag själv är ju inte bunden till, det är klart att jag tar ämne ofta men ibland tycker jag det är smidigt, jag ska ändå till Ikea ta ett skåp.
Eller ombudet är ändå förbi där.
Jag själv är ju också ganska situationsstyrd i hur jag väljer mitt leveransalternativ och det tror jag kommer att fortsätta.
Det är här flexibiliteten kommer in för konsumenten som jag tror kommer att bli ännu större.
Jag tror från leverantörernas perspektiv så är jag inte säker på att det alltid är konsolideringsvaror på allt för det är en komplex business.
Det är väldigt mycket saker som ska klaffa och alla bolag har sitt sätt att göra saker så det är inte alltid ett plus ett blir två.
Men fortsatta samarbeten mellan leverantörerna, när valkonsumenten har skett, att man kan flöda mellan sig på ett mer optimerat sätt än vad man kanske gör idag, vara mer öppna för samarbeten för att konsolidera leveranser.
Där har man ju en fördel som vidare, man har en kanske mer nyutvecklad teknik att kunna möjliggöra det.
Och det är väl någon där någonstans framtiden kommer att vara, mer optimerade lösningar, kanske mer konsolidering men inte alltid bolag som går ut, utan mer samarbete inom de leden och sen en fortsatt fokus på kundens upplevelse, deras val.
Det kommer vara fokus och jag tror inte vi kommer gå tillbaka i tiden och vill ha långsamma leveranser.
Det kommer behöva ske snabbt och det kommer behöva ske hållbart.
När du handlar och har smånehandlare, brukar du alltid lämna en dålig review om de inte har Airme?
Brukar du skriva typ, ja men bra leverans, alltså bra produkt men dålig leverans, borde ha haft Airme.
Har du gjort det nån gång?
Nej, det brukar jag faktiskt inte, men det brukar ju snarare mejla kunden och säga hej, jag beställde hos er, jag såg att ni erbjöd det här leveransalternivet, jag valde det, jag stod gent i tre dagar, det kom efter fem.
Alltså mer än att man kan nyttja det själv man har gjort för att kunna sälja in hur det också hade kunnat vara snarare.
Jag förstår, ja.
Så jag tänker att du hade gjort det även om du fick den efter tre dagar, men de kanske ser i spår ner om de orkar.
Ja, tre dagar tycker jag fortfarande långsamt, det finns möjlighet att förbättra så jag hade nog fortfarande mejlat kunden.
Ja.
Stort tack för att du var med i podden Elin.
Jättekul att höra hur ni var.
Ja men så kul att få sitta här och prata med dig.
Den hissen, det är inte så trevligt men den luknade kiss.
Det var ingen trevlig hiss, utan det var uppenbart någon som kissade i den hissen.
Jag kanske inte brydde mig as mycket om mitt jobb just då, så jag kanske då och då bara skedde.